[Music]
hi-yah so for this one I'm gonna break a
cardinal rule yes folks the Pandorica
opens and only the Pandorica opens cuz
you see most of the time actually
basically every other time unless I'm
specifically only talking about like
cliffhangers or otherwise done a list
that breaks these up I always review two
parters as a single story because that's
what I consider them to be two halves of
one continuous narrative but this time
I'm going to review each of these halves
separately because I don't feel that the
Pandorica opens flows seamlessly into
the Big Bang I actually think it's a
really jury [ __ ] and I have vastly
different feelings about each half of
this two-parter which I suppose once by
the time I'm done with this review
that's a spoiler warning for my thoughts
on the second half but that's getting
ahead of ourselves
the Pandorica opens finally we get the
culmination or the first half of the
culmination of the cracks in time
storyline we've heard the name Pandorica
dropped before what are the cracks where
did they come from what is this
Pandorica what's inside of it why does
everybody want it the answers are
actually pretty dang good for most of
these questions it's always tough
building up to a season finale
especially in Doctor Who it's difficult
to not have it feel like the big bads
kind of just sort of show up when you
need them to and sometimes that does
happen I would argue that kind of
happens in series three other times you
know you get a return of somebody who
we defeated them before but now they're
back and this one does a pretty good job
of upping the stakes from that while not
making it seem like it's nothing other
than one-upsmanship because whereas
normally we just have the Daleks or the
Cybermen or you know one single threat
usually the Daleks showing up now we
have almost everyone that we've seen
before and technically a bunch of ones
that we haven't seen in the new series
we don't actually see them but names get
dropped for classic era aliens do we
don't see because they didn't have the
costumes still sitting around but hey
still it's cool so how do you bring all
that together and not just make it feel
like you're going see I brought them all
here well you give them a really good
reason to do it and this does and a
better reason than just defeating the
doctor because obviously all these races
have wanted to defeat the doctor at one
point or another for one reason or
another but they've never joined forces
before so it was going to have to be a
threat much greater than the doctor
himself normally poses just on his own
and if they have inaccurately tied him
to the cracks in time and those cracks
in time indicate an explosion that
destroys the universe
well they assume it's him he's their
enemy anyways you get up and get
together everybody that hates him and
you go after you take this guy down and
that's what they do and it's it's pretty
cool it's pretty justified as far as
giving them a reason to actually work
together which is always the trick when
you're trying to do this kind of thing
as far as the whole thing of what's in
the Pandorica I clocked pretty early on
I suspect most people did that what was
inside the box or what was being
referred to as being inside the box was
the doctor cuz there's all this tale of
a trickster or a warrior would drop out
of the sky and you change your world you
know it's it felt very obvious that said
what I thought was going to happen was I
that they were gonna open that up and it
was going to be a future incarnation of
the doctor whether it actually be
something like the valley our door maybe
I thought maybe it was going to be Matt
Smith again just looking older but it
was none of those things it was empty
cuz he wasn't in it yet so while I did
call that all the myths of what was in
the Pandorica was referring to the
doctor and I was correct about that I
kind of liked that I didn't call on
first viewing that it was a trap that
they were going to put him into as
opposed to something that some
incarnation of him was already in I
thought that was kind of cool I thought
that was kind of clever there's a lot of
little touches I like about this river
is doing good work she's fun I mean like
how she smuggle in the loose and genic
lipstick into her freakin storm cage I
don't know that thing barely seems to
hold her anyway but whatever
we can't Rory back and I love how
low-key his reintroduction is he just
shows up trying to get the doctor's
attention and the doctors talking to him
it even says his name repeatedly but it
doesn't quite register what it is that's
going on and I love that he actually
says don't worry oh there's something
big I'm missing it's right in front of
me and I know I'm missing it Rory just
yeah I think you're probably right give
me a minute I'll get it he walks off
screen then just walks back I love that
I thought that was played terrifically I
think Rory's reaction to and his
desperation at trying to get Amy to
remember him again and his their initial
gut punch to him that she doesn't I
think that sells really well I
personally think that the idea that they
do with the Cybermen that this idea that
if the robotic components are still
working but the organic components have
died that it's gonna look for a new new
parts I kind of like that and that makes
sense to me now I'm sure some people
actually I've seen some people in like
forms and whatnot go like why don't
these things
do it otherwise I'm like well because
generally every other time we've seen
Cybermen destroy or at least Cybermen of
this level of advancement destroyed the
robotics weren't really left either
so like I'm prepared to accept that and
I it tracks for me again it there's a
very fun vibe but as its building
towards the end it goes dark quite well
as the doctor gets locked up as the
TARDIS begins to shake apart and explode
as Rory because of his programming
because he's actually anestine shoots
Amy this thing and then the freaking
universe explodes I ranked this very
high when I did my list of best
cliffhangers that the show is done this
is a really good cliffhanger this is the
epitome of how the heck do we get out of
this like on earth like every part of
this how do we got on this TARDIS
blowing up huh Amy's just been shot but
the doctors locked up ha the universe
exploded hey it's a pileup of how do we
get out of this and I think it works
very well again it could have just felt
like overload but it doesn't I don't
think it does at any rate so are there
any things that don't really work here
not really actually
I mean like there's tiny nitpicky things
like the like the loosen hallucinogenic
lipstick which I mentioned there's
things that bother me but not because of
here but because of some of the dangling
dangling plot threads and dangling ideas
between this and the Big Bang that never
really got properly tied off at least I
don't feel like they did but that's not
something to hold against this episode I
suppose if I was gonna complain
anything I or rather I'll touch on this
because it is something that I complain
about and I'm more or less okay with it
this time which is that the doctor
banking on his reputation in this guy in
this case literally just daring them all
these aliens flying around to come down
and take the Pandorica from him and he
just dares them and they back down well
a couple reasons I'm okay with that
first off it's actually kind of a ruse
since they're there waiting for him to
open it up so they could shove him into
it anyway so they're kind of playing him
way more than he knows but even setting
that aside just the fact that they are
there to take him down anyways I like
that within the same story his
reputation is invoked and it turns out
that it's the reason that everything is
going horribly wrong
I like that happening whereas some of
the instances where it's going to happen
later
first of all feel redundant and
repetitive because this kind of this is
kind of it this feels like this should
have been the capping off of the entire
premise of the doctors reputation has
gotten so big that you know these bad
things are now done specifically out of
fear of him I feel like this should have
capped off that idea so when it comes
back again in the next series it feels
repetitive it feels redundant and it
doesn't feel as properly and as it does
here at least I don't think it did and
maybe I'll feel different when I get to
the rewatch on that but that's sort of
like if this had been the last time the
doctor basically walked into a room said
I'm the doctor and everybody just went
through if this had been the last time
it's probably not something I would
complain about because this would have
been a this should have been the peak of
that hill but it wasn't but again that's
not even really a problem with this
episode that's a problem with something
that I get irritated as it comes up
later
but this episode by itself I think it's
great
is a great first half it's it manages to
be fun and bouncy and then just bring
everybody together for the size and
scope of the threat and then to go so
dark and to end on the cliffhanger it
does that's pretty impressive so come on
back in a week so I can tell you why it
completely falls apart in the second
half you seen the Pandorica opens again
lately if you have jobs something down
in the comments let's talk about it
there's a bunch of stuff to do as well
cuz you can like subscribe both of which
help me if you really want to assist you
can head on to the patreon and Chip me
in a buck a month or whatever you feel
comfortable giving it helps me cover my
bills and make the channel a bigger and
better thing hopefully so other good
links down there besides click on them
check things out or don't you don't have
to cuz at the end of the day folks
you're the council
I'm just running the meetings and until
next time this council is adjourned
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]